a warm welcome to the Academy of Motion
Picture Arts and Sciences for our annual
celebration of the nominated live-action
and animated shorts and of course soon
to be announced to Oscar shorts winners
are amongst these nominees I'm sure
you'll have your own opinions about that
tonight also brings a chance to hear
from our filmmakers and we have a very
special host for tonight who you'll get
to meet in a little bit I'm John bloom
chair of the short films and feature
animation branch and one of its three
governors along with Bill crore and Bob
Rogers this year we had a record
eligible sixty animated and a hundred
and forty-four live-action shorts which
came a third from our qualifying film
festivals and two-thirds via theatrical
screenings our big-screen reviewing
committee was well supplemented this
year by the availability for the very
first time of online streaming of all
the eligible films greatly increasing
our judging participation which gets us
to our second round of the ten
shortlisted shorts in each category also
newly available online judging
involvement skyrocketed by more than
triple and remains high within the full
Academy where our Oscar winners are
chosen the availability of our nominees
to Academy members on screenings and DVD
creates high voting levels in our
continuing efforts to support the wide
distribution of the nominated shorts we
are experiencing also a heightened
expansion in getting these shorts out to
an ever-widening and eager worldwide
audience in both box office and
ancillary
tribution channels box office is up a
strong thirteen percent this year in
North America hitting 49 states running
on 563 screens plus more than 180
additional screens internationally
projected to crest domestically at over
2.7 million dollars the addition this
year of all the big US theater chains
cinemark carmike AMC and regal who have
begun to exhibit the shorts is very
promising for the future the nominated
shorts will also be available the
nominated shirts will also be a bell
available for electronic sell-through
pay-per-view and video on demand our
growth in shorts distribution is making
is way to this again our growth and
shorts distribution is nothing short of
phenomenal I want to give a special
shout out to shorts HD or theatrical
distribution partner for over ten years
now who believed in this release and put
their money where their mouth is which
fostered this phenomenal growth
we have 10 great shorts upcoming so
allow me to introduce our MC for tonight
a master animator in addition to having
made a variety of significant creative
contributions to the DreamWorks films
Madagascar Sinbad simran and Kung Fu
Panda she is an oscar-nominated director
for Kung Fu Panda tube which earned a
worldwide box office hall of over
two-thirds of a billion dollars and yes
that's a be four billion and just now
directing again on Kung Fu Panda 3
currently in wide release we are proud
to have her as a member of the short
films and feature animation branch
executive committee and she is even
being seen now on TV in a heavily
running commercial can I please get a
little pandemonium as we welcome our
host for tonight Jennifer yuh Nelson
thank you John and thank you to the
Academy for having me here tonight we
are talking shorts tonight it's going to
be amazing so everyone I know wants to
make a short everyone all my friends in
animation or live-action big movie small
movie does not matter they always grab
me or there's meetings and they say I
have this crazy idea for a short I've
got to do this short come on let's do a
short I think why does everyone want to
do short so badly well there's a very
good reason because Schwartz can be
really weird in a short you could show a
guy getting shivved in a very
uncomfortable spot the whole thing could
be done in stick figures or you could
show a pregnant lady getting punched out
all of these things by the way you're
going to be seeing tonight so by the way
if there are little children in the
audience this may not be the most
appropriate venue that's very cool
shorts could scare moms in Poughkeepsie
we will take their kids traumatised in
the theaters they could scare investors
away screaming for the hills if there
are any investors they could have ending
so ambiguous that audience members will
be utterly confused and we be talking
about it for days and then you know
still be confused and they can be
utterly unprofitable freedom shorts are
subversive they are risky they are
experimental and they are by their
nature idiosyncratic and that is because
they are personal shorts are personal
projects made for personal reasons on a
personal scale they are direct main
lines into the weird and wonderful
brains that make them it's because of
this is shorts are truly well the purest
forms of our craft
tonight we're going to be seeing some
amazing shorts we're going to be seeing
five animated nominees and followed by
an amazing little panel then we're going
to be having an intermission and then
we'll be seeing the five live-action
nominees followed by their panel it's
going to be an amazing evening we're
going to see some beautiful things we're
going to take it some very very weird
and wonderful minds so I thank you for
coming tonight to honor the nominees and
their amazing work I hope that you guys
have an amazing fun and upbeat energy
night tonight and I think we should
start off by watching five animated
nominees for best for the for the
Academy Award so let's start with that
shall we thank you very much enjoy
yourselves and I'll see you in a little
bit
you
you
the prologue is something I'm just
completing now this is an idea for a big
film which I had when I was 15 years old
and I thought I wonder if I'll ever get
good enough to do this it's something
that nobody's just done and something
happened to me about three years ago I
know with all this teaching all this
experience is that it's like yogurt it
finally just went and I am able to do
exactly what I can think of and people
say what's this film about and and I say
well i'll tell you the working title and
so it's called will i love to finish
this and that i really hope i do if we
can stretch this out because it's an
enormous amount of work and i'm into
territory where people have tried to go
before and haven't brought it off
I keep thinking animation is so much
work and you have to learn is why I was
reluctant after my first bill that you
have to learn so much and and and I
don't know so I really want to do just
stuff that looks like cartoons but their
drawings that walk and talk and you can
put them anywhere and you can do
anything and it just seemed no but it's
going to be such a hard journey of
learning how to do all this stuff
because I wanted the whole ball of wax I
mean a lot of guys could very funny
artists are very funny animators they do
one kind of thing or but I wanted the
whole whammy sort of artistically greedy
or ambitious and he would have caught it
and that's what's my goal I thought it
doesn't matter what I do I got a master
this damn thing so I can really do
anything I want and I fortunately have
achieved it well I'm still reasonably
healthy and walking around
you
you
you
with the nominees please come up on
stage
my costly one my chair we need one more
chair apparently someone get a chair 10
jab one more chair please your vertice
chair request oh well while we're
waiting for a chair why don't we
introduce our panel so would you mind
going down the row and introducing her
into yourselves hi my name is Gabrielle
Osorio I am the director of birth story
my name is Pato escala and I'm the
producer of birth story i'm richard
williams and i'm the animator of
prologue I'm Imogen Sutton and I'm
producer of prologue
my name is Sanjay Patel and hopefully
you know my movie I'm Nicole Grindle and
I'm the producer of Sanjay super team i
am konstantin bronzy i am from cosmos
and she says she's daughter of my friend
she just will help me to understand what
you are talking about it us later first
of all congratulations to all of you and
not all of you are first-timers there of
course multi nominees and winners here
but congratulations for all of you for
being nominated for Best Animated Short
so I'm going to actually go down the
line and talk a little bit about first
inspirations and then process there's
actually a lot of great stories behind
the shorts that we saw today and I was
wondering if you could speak first
Gabriela belt bear story and about where
that story came from mm-hmm and well
versed or is really for me a very kind
of a personal story like a family story
and in some way talks a little bit about
the story of chili and I don't know if
you if you know something about the
story of chili and back in 1973 there
was this military regime that took all
the socialist government a away from the
country style then and get a lot of
people killed so and one of those people
that works for the government was my
grandfather so I I grew up without
knowing my grandfather he he was in jail
and then in Europe in Europe for for
like 20 years so him it really was hard
for me growing as a kid and seeing that
my government didn't allow me to meet my
grandfather and didn't allow him to
return to his country only for his
political vision so
it was really a something that I always
feel that was very wrong wrong very
awful and I try and I try to put that in
the in the in the movie you know to tell
the importance of the family to eat
together and and try to try to make a
movie that was a very telling in a like
in a way that could be seen by kids
bye-bye new generation so try to get a
message through to the audience that
maybe that we can we must try to not
make the same mistake of of the best
again so I think that's where the movie
really comes from and also part of the
the location the actual world that said
it's actually based on an actual
neighborhood right the actual
neighborhood of Chile the the location
of the actual bear story was set on it
was it your childhood neighborhood yeah
yeah a lot of a lot of the things of the
film was inspired by my childhood by the
houses of her grandfather's there is the
lot of integration we took from Chile
and and in that sense i think is very a
very Latin America movie but at the same
time it's talked about a universal
universal feelings I really try not to
be literal about the story but try to
express the feeling and and emotions
that has to do with with exhale it's
amazing story thank you so much
so tato what does this feel for you is
very personal story for him what does it
feel for you to produce this short well
when Gabrielle first arrived with the
treatment and we we really in the in the
studio everybody get really a sad it was
a very sad story and we we really wanted
to join him in the journey that that he
was inviting us and it was a very long
journey it was almost four years and a
lot of the team that work in the in the
short film is here with us today because
this is a great achievement not only for
not only for Gabrielle and for the team
it's a great achievement for all the
Chilean animation and for latin american
animation right now you know there is
orchard women brazilian future filming
in competition also so it's amazing for
us to be representing all these talented
creators and all these artists from
Latin America so we're very very happy
to be here today wonderful thank you so
Richard and Imogen you're amazing short
prologue apparently this story has been
rattling around in your mind since you
were 15 years old you talk about the
creation of this short what's another
sad story when I was a kid that I was
very struck when we blew up Nagasaki and
Hiroshima and then I visited we visited
new Russia Russia maharashtra later my
uncle's were in the war when was a
photographer d-day now there was a
Spitfire pilot another raid airplanes
for the ball anyway we just it's just
the constant utility of what of human
behavior
and the innocence of the kid I suppose
is hopeful but the mother grandmother
whatever has seen it all before that's
an amazing amazing story Imogen how did
you get presented your longtime
collaborators the two of you how did you
get introduced to this idea and why did
you feel that it would make such a great
short well I think that it's very hard
to portray the reality of war I mean we
all see films war films and so on a lot
of live action but there's something
about drawing and drawing the horror of
what men can do to each other which is
particularly potent I mean I did notice
this evening that there were certain
moments in the film when there were
serious gasps from the audience and I
think despite the fact we've all seen a
lot of horrible things on film there's
something about drawing which conveys a
very powerful message and it was
originally I think dick was thinking
about just having the four men kill each
other which shows the total futility of
war but then I I sort of introduced the
idea that we had to have something
hopeful and something positive which
which came in the form of the little
girl and something about the female
figure the hope the other side the
people who watch destruction and the
woman the old woman at the end is very
important I think to show us how how war
goes on and on and things don't change
so there's hope and there's hopelessness
thank you
Sanjay and Nicole stand a super team
this is the very first autobiographical
short by Pixar so this is obviously
based on a mostly true story he said can
you talk about what this story was and
how this became a short for you your
name on it so i was pretty I'd been
working at Pixar for about 10 years and
I think I just kind of hit this burnout
period where you know it's kind of a
just a hardcore student of American
animation American Art European art and
I'd went to three different art schools
and nobody had ever opened my eyes to
Asian Art and it was only after really
scratching that itch with animation and
working on so many great films at Pixar
that I finally the window sort of opened
up to like taking some new art and some
new inspiration and I discovered a book
of miniature paintings from India and in
the book they had images from my father
shrine at home and I'd seen these images
all throughout my life but I never read
the stories and I didn't know who these
characters were and what the philosophy
or the story or the sort of the
philosophy behind what the image is
trying to convey and so once I actually
read the story behind the pictures
that's when I really became activated
and just totally inspired because what I
saw was these amazing characters he's
amazing stories timeless wisdom and I
was like wow this is all the things that
we try to go for our pics aren't even
more and so many of my friends at Pixar
just didn't know anything about it and I
was the first one that was clueless and
so in many ways it was just for me to
just educate myself and so I would spend
all my nights and weekends reading as
much as I could and I would do these
sort of book reports which became these
little picture books and illustrated
sort of graphic novels that I'd make and
I was really satisfied doing that and I
think that's when I kind of hit this
kind of point where it was like oh man
I'd have to choose because I was like
working all day at Pixar and at night I
was also
working and you just becoming too much
and I was fortunate to have a couple of
two different art shows at the asian art
museum in san francisco and john
lasseter happened to come across the
artwork because we have actually a small
gallery at the studio and they had
actually invited me just put up so my
art there and so John saw it and he's
like oh man you gotta like you gotta
make a short and and so different
producers that contacted me and I just
kept saying no to it because I just
didn't believe it well AI didn't want to
be a director there's nothing in me that
wants to do that I'm really happy
working by myself when nobody's looking
and nobody cares when somebody's looking
and somebody's karen's and somebody has
money I just freaked out very scary but
but yeah and so they find they asked a
third time and I finally talked to my
dad about it and you know I told him
what was happening and he was like you
know sanjay he's like you know the
studio had supported me for the better
part of almost 15 20 years at that point
and he just thought that for me to not
at least try to do what they're asking
me to do would essentially create bad
karma that would be you know very bad
for me
karma is a word that he takes very
seriously he felt in fact that it was my
duty it wasn't just my job that it was
my duty to at least try to do what they
were asking me to do and and I tried and
I realized that I was just incredibly
scared to put myself out there son so
Nicole as a producer did you have to
push him to do this well once that we
got together he was on the road to
making the film and you know just just I
wanted to comment on what others had
said about their stories being you know
based on sad events and you know I think
to some extent this story was as well
you know the alienation of someone who's
the child of an immigrant both from
their parent and from the American
culture you know and I I think it's been
a really happy homecoming for for sunjai
and for a lot of the people who worked
on the film actually and we found when
we've shown the film a lot of people
have come and said you know as an
immigrant they felt that they weren't
represented in mainstream media and you
know their experience wasn't wasn't
valued and therefore they didn't feel
valued and so it's been really exciting
I wanted to say to be a part of that
that story and and 2i hope inspire other
similar kinds of stories so yes when I
started working with him he was on the
path to already he had accepted the call
to make the film and then you know we
had an opportunity to build a team like
I said many of whom came from a similar
experience and it was great i mean the
nice thing about working on a short film
in a big studio is it's so much more
intimate experience for the people on
the team when you're on a feature there
are really big teams they work in
departments you don't feel like you're
you know a part of the the filmmaking
experience at its core but on a short
film everybody gets to do that and it
was really collaborative Sanjay is a
really collaborative director and you
know it was just a great experience
overall for the story and also for the
filmmaking experience thank you
Constantine so this idea for this film
came from a dream apparently would you
like to talk about oh you know I've
never had a drink understood you think
sorry I speak not so good like my
colleagues I just was listening my
colleagues and realized how animators
are crazy really my god and see it took
so long time from each of us to make so
short short films yeah only crazy people
can do it yes well yes did you seen my
fin in the middle of my feeling one shot
is the float in bed with two men on it
in big space it was image which come to
me in my dream it's not a tail it's it's
true really and a lot of radish a lot of
radish can condemn here but this time I
just when I wake up I just start sinking
what it was something strange sumption
something strange in this image in five
minutes of sinking update I developed
all story to the very beginning and to
the very end it never happened to me
before I thought like that that a the
stories like this when directors tell
it's like it's specialist stuff for
audience for prayers I never believed in
them till it happen to me it's
incredible really but it it's true be
careful with your dreams
but you also spoke about how this was an
exercise in showing loneliness could you
talk a little bit about that how do you
know everything about me I've researched
it oh yes it's about loneliness really
if you just if for the first look it's
like about friendship but if you look a
bit a little bit more profound yes
you're right it's about loneliness
because the links between people which I
show in my films it doesn't they don't
exist in real life I would like that
such a kind of links to be at least
partly in real life they but they don't
exist it's a pity for me that's why we
it would every everybody was a little
bit lonely that's that's my salt thank
you getting close to time but I do want
to ask about process because so much of
these films have such a different look
from each other each one is utterly
unique did you briefly talk about why
you chose a technique that you chose to
better tell your story we start with you
Gabrielle and what we use release
primarily CG 3d film but we use a lot of
a real media a pictures of drawings that
we put in the backgrounds there are
there are apart there is a cutout
animation so we really try to use
different techniques to try to get a
loop that in some way where most unique
to us to our studio to the that
represents in some way the animation
that we are making in until I so it's
really a mix it mix a kind of way make
of mega chip animation awesome thank you
and Richard he chose a hand-drawn
obviously because of your history is
being while the greatest animators ever
but why at this particular look for this
story that's that's the way I naturally
draw I don't draw like Roger Rabbit I
mean I do it for its commission word
this is and I always did the best I
could with whatever they I lived like a
chameleon and this is me this is the
crew thank thank you very much yeah I
really appreciate it so that's what it
is thank you free of pleasing other
people thank you and that's all why did
you choose a style that you chose for
yours so um I'm not a fan of 3d I know
that might go kind of anti to what I've
made but if you look at any one of my
picture books and graphic novels I love
to d I'm just a sucker for drawing and
just something flat and I'm just a big
fan of that but the subject matter that
we're doing I knew straight away that I
didn't want to do something flat in fact
I wanted to really have what I really
wanted this thing to happen that only
that took me 30 years which was I really
wanted this I don't know my parents
culture to really take on more dimension
than 2d I wanted to have three
dimensions I wanted to have more than
three dimensions in fact they there's a
3d version a stereo version of the short
film that just looks astounding and we
really sort of turned the knobs on that
especially once the deities are
incarnated and so um when we were sort
of everything that I had read and
everything that I'd seen India about the
temple carvings trying to illuminate and
illustrate oh gosh these experiences of
enlightenment that's what these temples
are there these artisans we're working
at the best of their abilities and I
just thought like wow we have more
tools in our toolbox at Pixar and it
just felt like I really want to take it
that extra level that the philosophies
couldn't know those artists couldn't and
so that was the drive that was the urge
is to really have this kind of
enlightenment sort of transcendental
experience for this little boy wonderful
thank you wanted to say we also have the
2d cartoon in their soul tip of the hat
to what sunjai was originally inspired
by a cipher Didion paper to do thank you
in Constantine why did you choose a
style that you chose to tell your story
Oh what are you talking about the actual
I mean I mean when you say something
about my style in my film it's nation'
it's it's it's most stupid seen in my
film that's the stuff just because I had
no money for 3d it's ads funny for you
not for me and I asked one of my
colleagues to be our director and I
didn't pay him money but he he agreed
yes thank thanks to him and I wanted to
be my feel most simple way as possible
because well I didn't want to press with
some very very artificial at artistic
visual style that's all yeah thank you
thank you
and down hearts felt for World of
Tomorrow could be her today but he sends
his regards so congrats to him from afar
and congrats to all of you nominated
this year good luck figure out of a
pause and please take your seat alright
we will be having a short intermission
and then we'll be going to the live live
action shorts after that so you'll see
you back
motto midd cavalli de Vaca she will go
out a machete can we use your focus
hey behind neck
this is my first job
yeah it's very mission response and she
knows there's a monkey on CTA put y ou
manor houses the face Ethan soon the
holes of its official first on lovin
fine mr. Hauser it's nice test signal
and competed as a sustainable Georgia
nice large just took my light stick
mellitus kidney thunders asking me is
give me down the session starts oh ah
yummy sets is a sea cierto it comes on
this end on it is here I've also missing
us imagine mission does yets Markham the
late night it's good to me fine yes it's
not hold again constant
you
pthread the stores macomb to his vision
shalleg oil and you book a pony
Oh
Oh
snap judgement 1226 reclusive
typographer invisible to the naked eye
communication skills of an infant excels
in the art of self-pity hello with the
nominees please come up the stage
all right would you please introduce
yourselves to the audience one at a time
starting from you my name is basil I'm
the director of ave maria my name is
Hank Hughes I wrote and directed day one
my name is Patrick I made everything
will be okay my name is Jamie Donaghey
I'm the writer and director shock I'm
Benjamin Clary I wrote and directed
stutter
I'm Serena armitage and I'm one of the
producers of stattera first of all
congratulations to all of you for your
nomination and today we'll just talk a
little bit about your creative process
and where your ideas came from so basil
could you please speak first about where
your idea for your short of American
from and interestingly your father has a
bit of a religious background is this
something that gave you a perspective to
the material well my father is a
preacher from Nazareth evangelical not
Catholic but next to her house was a
caramelized convent it was in big
massive convent with seven nuns who live
in total silence and I was preparing for
a feature totally different but I
thought I need to do a short film and I
was quite curious about these nuns who
live in a bubble and so I thought what
would be most annoying to them is to
bring a bunch of nosy family into their
house and just mess up their silence and
so when you're in Palestine and Israel
you've got some Palestinian nuns what do
you bring in to mess up their day some
Jews so I'm I wanted to do a comedy of
awkward situation for these people it's
a total nightmare with a situation
they're in for us is funny because we
live outside that bubble it's wonderful
has already been very much appreciated
by a great audience you've you actually
have it being screened on many different
networks now you actually have it I've
had a few yeah yes it's a no not yet
we've sold it to you but it's also
they're all screening it on Oscar night
for ceremony wonderful thank you and one
thing before I move on actually like to
point out you've actually managed to
meld comedy and religion together which
is something that's actually very touchy
and somehow managed to make people
appreciate that so something that you
are thinking about doing when you are
creating this sort of bring everyone
gather from different religions
especially with your background for for
me because I was brought up in Palestine
Israel is the Holy Land and you've got
all the three religions and everybody's
bashing that they're right right and and
then when you look at the neural it's
the same really and they just speak
different languages but it is somewhat
absurd of how similar they are and how
different they are and like being young
and my parents dragged me to church
three times a week you know you kind of
fall asleep in him daydream so this is
my little rebellion wonderful thing here
now I Henry so two tours in Afghanistan
so you have a bit of experience to draw
from to come up with this short yeah
it's um yes I was an arm for like five
years a two tours in Afghanistan on my
second tour I had a female interpreter
she's just like Afghan American girl
that was really cool and I just figured
when the time came to make a movie that
her point of you would probably be
somehow able to illuminate things that
say a story about someone like me we'd
already seen that story so many times
and somehow this like woman very much in
a man's world hopefully within a very
like kind of like feminine issue we
could maybe look at the masculine world
that way that's really amazing
especially since with your own personal
experience being there I mean writing
this material trying to get people to
see what it was like and what were you
trying to get people to access when
you're making this film sure yeah
actually some people talked about
earlier some of the animators and
there's some other war film through to
sign it will probably address it but
we've seen a lot of violence in combat
and it's it's to the point that it
doesn't really phase us anymore so it's
how can you find something that will
affect you so that you know the big
obstacle is that I don't know what like
to
deuce what war felt like her really what
worries but I could tell you what it
feels like and so to find some sort of
conduit that could translate that and so
I thought maybe going to creation in
birth and a very feminine area might get
us to a point that there's something
that is you can get to those sublime
moments of things that are shocking and
scary and also beautiful and precious
thank you I think you heard the shock
audience the reaction everybody's going
well with the baby and all that stuff so
I think you've achieved that and also
you've actually mentioned your muse the
translator that you were talking about
you talk a little bit about her what
your interactions with her was like
there what you saw her actually yes I
mean every Afghan that I met she was my
voice and it got to the point that I
would wear like a dog's leash on my body
armor and she would hold the other end
because it was like tough for her to
like walk at night it's really tough
actually don't you guys ever walked at
night but it takes a long time to get
used to it you know it's there's
something about like Siri on your phone
is program as a default as a female
voice or like your gps is a female voice
and every military equipment it's always
a female voice of the machine or like
the computer on it's because it cuts
through like a tank crew or a cockpit or
somehow it just the feminine voice like
there was this one female pilot he'll
hook helicopter pilot and you hear her
come on the radio once every wall and
everyone just stop and listen and
there's something about that when you
had a woman is your voice it gave you a
new perspective wow thank you
so Patrick so how did you come up with
this story and and what is it this
special for you um it started all out
with them a newspaper article I read an
article about a father who kidnapped its
own child during a divorce and I was
always wondering i was reading a lot
about that and it was already questioned
myself like how can someone like a
parent do something to his kid that is
so bad for a kid and claimed in the end
that he's doing it out of love and that
was a question i was traveling with I
went on a big research trip I talked to
to a lot of two parents who went through
this two fathers and mothers both sides
to police two psychologists to judge and
all so I want to get like every single
detail and I yeah and out of all this
kind of information I God then I wrote
this as a screenplay it's kind of based
on a true event but I put in everything
a guy from all this research so true
event in the aggregate as opposed to
seeing the true vent was kind of you
know the starting point and I got a lot
of you know every every kind of detail
someone told me like the beginning that
picking up his kid and don't even look
at the mother because you hate her so
much and all this kind of stuff in that
my you know i'm i wrote like every
everything in this one one story that's
amazing and certainly the performance
that you actually got for the actors to
play lea who had never performed before
as an actress no she's it was her first
appearance in the film ever she did
something at you know theater at school
but doesn't really count and yeah it was
really her you know we did a lot of we
would cast it half a year like kind of
every kid in Vienna so
but yeah I'm pretty pretty lucky 22
found her she seems to be the most
mature person in the entire movie yeah
that's right said was when I was editing
that I was always think about that's the
only really grown up you know who like
act grown up and and they even the
police you know there Eric everybody is
like crazy and she's the only one wears
like knows what's right and but I kind
of feel that kids are so often and they
kind of know what's right because they
didn't get messed up was like growing up
and know how the world it's like not yet
you know that's really wonderful thank
you so Jamie sorry hi so shocked
apparently this is the first nominated
film from Kosovo made with a crew from
Kosovo and based on a true story can you
talk about where this idea came from
okay it's in all honesty I knew nothing
about Kosovo at all and in 2010 I
visited the country for three days and
then on the second day the icelandic
volcano erupted and five weeks later I
was still in the country I'm a conga fly
out and that's that's where I got
introduced to the country and I met some
incredible amazing people and I began to
learn about these stories that happen
there during the war and I I just
couldn't believe what had happened on
our doorstep less than 15 years ago and
very few people knew about this and I
just felt that I had to do something
about it so over the next four years I
went back and forth and researched as
much as I possibly could about the
country and what had happened and spend
time with the families until I wrote
this film and yet you writes the
first-ever nomination for Kosovo and
I've just got to say as well as most of
my UK crew half the Kosovan crew and
cast of flown all the way out here to be
here today some really really honored
we've done
very powerful must mean a great deal for
the country and the people there to
actually have this level of recognition
yes I think I mean the support we've had
from the country it was it was very hard
to to tackle this in know whether it was
the right time or not to tackle it and
how best to do it as well and I
approached it by I understood that I was
an international coming over telling
these stories but I did my very best to
really understand what went on and
really understand the culture over there
and although I wasn't nervous about
showing this a response we've had from
Kosovo has been amazing and people have
said that they're very grateful that
these stories have finally been heard
thank you very much okay so Benjamin and
Serena apparently you guys were
roommates when you came up with this
idea that's right yeah yeah okay talk
about the genesis of this idea how he
got it together sure yeah would the
initial idea actually came I was a
online i saw something about this
gentleman who you know had a pretty
severe speech difficulty but he gotten
to the point where face-to-face he was
you know it was pretty much
imperceptible but when he would get on
the phone it was just all come flooding
back because it was just his voice on
show you know this just really it struck
a chord at me it really stayed at me
this idea and I started to think about
you know what it might be like
navigating through life with something
like this with your you know ability to
express yourself sort of taken away and
and you know I had a good friend growing
up who had a severe stutter so I got to
see firsthand what that was like and you
know I think growing up anyways is so
difficult and has so many challenges but
if you get the ability to express
yourself taking away you know becomes
even more of a challenge so I kind of
had that personal attachment i think to
the idea and but in terms of the script
it was it was really it was one of those
scripts where as i was writing at these
ideas started coming you know to me
about like for instance exploring the
dichotomy between his interior world
which is wonderful and kind of you know
charming and then you know his external
world
which is you know much more cut off and
to do you use voiceover to try and you
know portray that and these kind of
ideas were exciting me as I was writing
so you know that's a good sign for me if
I get the end early and I get these you
know things that are keeping me almost
like an audience member excited it's a
good sign so you know that was happening
with the script and then you know
luckily I had you know great friends and
like Serena and Shan the other producer
and you know who warmed the script and
were just incredibly supportive and even
though it was crazily ambitious sort of
thing to make on five grand they said no
do it will support it will jump on board
with the vision so yeah it was it was
great it was it was you know I couldn't
have done it without those guys and you
know everyone who was involved as a
Michael patio Deimos the DP is here in
the audience to and his first ever film
to go glad so I'm and Nicko casal de at
the wonderful composer is here too with
us so yeah Serena would you like to talk
about it some of the dynamic of how this
came about with bunch of great bunch of
friends together yeah I mean we knew we
wanted to do something together we
talked about a few ideas and benadryl in
several really good scripts but I think
when we read the script for stutterer
both Sean and I on a first reading were
really kind of moved by it and just kind
of felt it was definitely the one and
then actually been was working in studio
with Michael and had seen that he had a
great talent and wanted to get him on
board and then Nico the composer was
also a friend of somebody who's in
studio so we're all kind of really close
to each other in Hackney Shannon live
just down the road so it was a it was
great to do a project like that with
such a you know core group of mates
where because it's pretty much a we
talked about for 18 months so all over
early friends how it is yeah way Tony
else left no yeah it's a pretty much all
we were talking about so but you know
the nice things that we started this I
you know
you know good friends and became even
better friends and and and you know
we're still really good friends after
after all this this time which is which
is nice he helps you to go other way so
yeah that's very good thank you very
much so I'd actually like to talk a
little bit about I think you've done a
of a feature film right you've done a
film that and beyond a short not yet
documentaries what you've done a longer
format film but now that you guys have
done a short and gone through the
process going through the short are you
feeling like the short process helped
you tell your story better than a longer
format story or is it something that you
feel like you really want to continue on
to do a feature film for me I'm moving
on to a feature film but I learned so
much during this short that it kind of
altered my strategy am i working on my
feature film whether it's my writing
skills have developed or choosing my
next project I had one lined up and I
thought okay if it was this stuff making
it short it's going to be tougher doing
that feature so maybe I'll do something
a bit more manageable so my next film is
a bit more manageable than my original
plan how about you Henry um I love the
short format I think it you can really
do so much with so little it's almost
like a unplugged album or something so i
will miss making shorts but i do want to
move on and try a longer form i think
that you can really dive into people's
lives and features or really dive into
lives and some of great televisions
happening right now Patrick um you know
when I was never thinking about like
that was a story I wanted to tell and it
fit on nine pages of of a treatment so
and it's a thesis film for my film
school and I would come up with like I
want to make it features i would look at
me and say 'no no so they're worse you
know but i'm writing a feature right now
and yeah I you know in film school kind
of have to do shorts because there is no
much more money
and I but you know it's very good when
you can do something in a couple of days
and try out a lot and maybe fail with
what you're doing and then move on to
the next thing and that's very good 22
and making shorts and especially in film
school to be honest making us sure felt
like making a feature it was a it was a
lot of hard work I love the short format
I think a lot of people under eight and
understand don't sit on how hard it is
to get right and but I think next I
would love to go back to Kosovo but I
would go like to go further into the
stories and that would be more in a
feature side i would say yeah i'm i'm
hoping to move on to write a feature now
which will be you know loosely
thematically linked to disorder but not
the same characters but i think you know
the short format and it's it's a great
thing because it teaches you how to be
very economical with your with your
writing you know everything that and
should get dropped it doesn't you know
progress a story or advanced character
you know has to get dropped and you've
got to get to the point very quickly and
be concise so i think it's a really good
learning platform and i'm going to make
another short i think what and you know
develop a feature alongside that yeah
and just to UM in terms of the short
form again what you said earlier about
sort of them allowing you know them
being weird i thought that was great and
very true and like what i love about the
short format is the fact that allows
people to be experimental and you don't
have so many voices feeding in and you
can really make something that is your
own product so i'd always like to keep
making shorts as well as doing features
as well hopefully wonderful to wrap up
what each of you like to say what you
wished your audience members would get
after seeing this film especially after
seeing the reactions from the crowd
watching your film what do you wish the
people who walk away from your short
would be feeling well for me everybody
tends to see images from the Middle East
in the Arab world in a certain way I'd
like him to walk
having seen something a bit different on
a human level and you know just showcase
what Arab cinema could be you know it's
it's funny like at some point your film
isn't your film anymore I mean it's like
I have some actress here and some people
from AFI my producer my editor my sim
tog referred it's like their film too
and then it's your film when you watch
it and you take your life and you look
at it through that lens and so it's
almost like I can only present what I
felt was honest and I think it's up to
you to figure out what you think about
it I used to hate that answer but like
the more people who've seen the film
like the lessons becomes mine I start to
understand why people say that um you
know I wanted to make I kind of hate to
tell afterwards what I wanted to tell
because I won't show it in the 30
minutes I got so you know I wanted to
make a small and truthful film and you
know I hope that that comes along yeah I
cell with a very simple message that I
was just hoping that just maybe one or
two people would begin to look at the
this area in the country Kosovo him what
had happened there and obviously since
all of this a lot more people looking at
it so I'm very I'm very grateful for
that but I think more so the message I
was trying to put across by presenting
you through children is that em in a way
that every and our lives are so similar
but yet so different just because of
where we're born but these things are
continuing to happen and history is
repeating itself and that's very sad so
hopefully if this film can go some way
to highlight in that and making people
think then that would be great yeah I
think I'd echoes you know some of the
guys saying I think what you take home
from a film is a very personal thing to
every person and if someone you know
watches the film and they're affected by
it and it speaks to them that's great
and you know if it gets people to look
at some of the issues sort of dealt with
in the film in a new light that's
amazing too but yeah for me it Sam it's
when you when you make a film you
presented
it's everyone's personal take home i
think and i agree really exactly the
same my favorites of reactions when
someone says something has a fresh take
on the film that i haven't heard before
and you know people are discussing it
and talking about it means wonderful
well congrats to all of you your films
are amazing let's give a big hand of a
blog thank you very much thank you very
much